as a great disappointment trying to be
generous and kind on this yes the
immediate aftermath and 911 he did a
good job and going into Afghanistan I
think he did a very good job he waited
it enough till there was a
infrastructure there in the US military
approach and he really kept taps on it
and explained it well to the American
people got the international community
involved with all of NATO now involved
in Afghanistan so I think he did a very
good job on something like that and then
with Iraq he did I thought it was very
brave going into Iraq and I do think
that Clinton would have done the same
thing in that situation but of course
you know Clinton doesn't say that now
but I do believe that after nine eleven
almost any president would have done
that but I think that he will be seen a
as even though he had an MBA masters of
business administration from Harvard is
the least capable business administrator
in the presidency Lincoln who never ran
anything linking a tattoo man law firm
okay with herndon and never ran in
office never you know did anything he
proved to be an executive that was
exceptional as an executive here we have
a president who has a Harvard MBA and he
can't keep people accountable can't
appoint good people can't hold them to
accountability can't fire them if they
totally mess up and to me it's
inexcusable
well Henry the fifth father enter the
fourth was ruling the land while the kid
was drinking too much cavorting in the
bars and everything like that and so the
analogy with george herbert walker bush
where george w bush was drinking too
much cavorting the bars and horsing
around like crazy fit very well both
young prince hal and george w bush
became president in a very disputed kind
of way here we had the Florida chads
there and then the two of them got in a
war that is still highly controversial
and is being debated all these years
later so the analogy fits very well we
were invited to a small dinner at the
White House years ago for Shakespeare's
birthday and it was a great event I was
called one day and just answered the
phone I'm social secretary of the White
House the president and mrs. Bush would
like to have you at a small dinner and
in 10 days time man can you make it and
I said well let me check the eye and
calendar and the social secretary says
no one's ever said that to me before and
so I said well you're in luck we can do
it so we went there and then I talked to
the I was talking to Tom Wolfe it was a
great writer and I'm known to run before
and bush and the president came up to us
and told Tom Wolfe he was just reading
his book then and so we chatted about
that and then mentioned Shakespeare and
I said to the president that there was a
lot of analogies between him and Henry
the fifth and he was very nice about it
but I got the idea that he had no idea
what I was ever talking about and I was
not anxious and to do the analogy
because it's not terribly flattering